welcome to the dark forest checking your
pals were there for for us shameless
confession about our obsession will make
us laugh and smile so let's explore the
dark forest hey you guys it's me Jackie
Kashian that's right first Ranger among
Rangers of the dark forest you're
listening to the door for us the
websites of course are the dark forest
calm just regular dork force calm goes
right to it there's a family pet
ancestry.com that goes to Jackie Kashian
calm because it may have been laughs all
things comedy calm has a dork force page
and that is because that is my podcast
umbrella network and they have a lot of
other podcasts on on their website if
you're looking for other pods to listen
to a lot of stand-up comics have their
podcasts on there al Madrigal and bill
burr of course being the most famous the
credits let's do it Patrick Brady's
going to fix this audio my GRIK work
composed and sang the intro song to the
dork forest he will sing again his words
to the Mexican Hat dance at the end and
Vilmos fixes Jackie Kashian calm he will
be fixing up the merch page and making
everything more expensive so if it's $25
for a t-shirt with shipping its thirty
dollars then that is taken into account
that postage has gone up and yeah I
raised the prices but it all includes
shipping all the merch I might as well
talk about it if you go to Jackie
Kashian calm on the merch page the store
page you can get Ranger the dork forest
t-shirts the dork forest t-shirts I'm
phasing out the brown ones it's just
going to be green so but I have some
left in stock and I'm going to bring
them on the road they're all union made
all the t-shirts they are made in the
united states of america by union
workers who have dental and health care
very glamorous and so hence they run
bank just cnl because they're made by
union members and Americans and we
proudly I guess or with some shame are
slightly larger than other people you
can also get all of my CDs my CDs are
available digitally on Amazon
iTunes you can just also stream them on
Pandora or Spotify but you can buy hard
copies on my website so there's the
first one circus people hard copy in vol
includes a quicktime video from my 2003
comedy central special the it's never
going to be bread which was top 10
comedy albums of the year in 2010 when
it came out on amazon.com and my new one
which came out last year was top 5
comedy specials of the year on vulture
calm and that is called this will make
an excellent Horcrux this will make an
excellent Horcruxes available as a CD as
a DVD or as a downloadable ten-dollar
special on comedy film nerds calm which
i also write movie reviews for you can
get just a town a download of it the DVD
itself has a DVD bonus and I can sign
anything I cannot sign things there is a
new t-shirt and it is the spooky reading
girl t-shirt a reference of from my act
okay other than that the LA podcast
festival is coming up you guys it's
where everybody gathers and if you're
coming to it go to LA pod fest calm and
buy tickets and come to the podcast
festival it's the weekend of September
19th if you can't make it you can live
stream all of them for a month all of
the different podcasts are being filmed
and then live streamed and then saved
for a month so you can buy them all for
twenty-five dollars if you are not going
to be able to make the podcast festival
and you would like my podcast and
everybody else's podcast in the whole
world Marc Maron's podcast is going to
be there aisha tyler's podcast is going
to be there thrilling adventure hour
hours doing one paul Gilmartin who was
just on the show and you can live stream
all of it it's $25 for all of them you
can save five bucks if you use my code
which is dork do RK oddly enough and
then it's 20 bucks for everybody my
podcast is going to be 4 p.m. on
saturday September 19th my guests will
be Greg Proops and then I'm also doing
Paul Gill Martin's podcast that night
where we will open a vein and talk about
any sort of mental illness that I might
have because he has a thing called
mental
pod Paul Gilmartin that's at 10pm all
these times are Pacific now when I do
the live shows now I'd make them premium
episodes that's on bandcamp so if you go
to probably bandcamp com / the dork
forest I know there's a link and there's
special their special premium episodes i
think they cost two dollars because
sometimes the live ones cost money to
put up with the audio guy and the travel
and the hotelling's whatever other than
that there's of course a donation button
on both dork 4s calm and Jackie
tkachenko where he can donate to the
show if you are enjoying the show feel
free to donate uh this has been a weird
you're financially and so if you like
the show you could donate ten bucks a
month I haven't made that easy because i
don't like regular money coming out of
anything so you just have to remember oh
I like the show here's ten dollars and
I'd love a hundred dollars from
everybody that's what I would love if
you have a hundred dollars a year I
would love that and if you have more God
knows I would love that too but whatever
you like whatever you could afford and
if you can't afford any of it that's
fine don't worry about it I'm glad you
liked the show talk it up you can also
support the show by buying merch which
we talked about or using the amazon
banner on Jackie Kashian com which is
when you order from amazon and we all do
i'm almost shirt certain we all do i
know it only works with the US version
of amazon though but you click through
to the US version of amazon you do your
order just like normal and it supports
the show a little bit and it doesn't
cost you anything extra on amazon i do
stand-up comedy Jackie Kashian does and
there is a tour page on Jackie Kashian
calm that tells you where I'll be doing
it it's an exciting time feel free to
come and see me live but for the love of
everybody in their grandmother let's get
into the dorkdom of the day thanks for
listening you guys let's do this it's
Jackie Kashian talking into a new mic so
the piece might pop see get that Patrick
Brady told me to purchase some
windscreens I'm gonna be sitting a
little bit away I'm here in my living
room with jay mohr welcome to the dork
force my friend I'm impressed with the
windscreens more impressed with the
windsock above your home if I only bring
in that Cessna there's the wind sock and
the chime are two things Andy ashcraft
will have no part of other chimes at
airports next to the wind socks how
great would that be no I've never seen a
chime in at airport but don't begin land
that plane today look at those chimes
jobs would be the most loudest chimes in
the world I picked the wrong sense for
chimes I said look instead of listen
like a dope Oh Jay Mohr we've done each
other's pods before yes super radio show
on the Fox thing sports okay let's talk
about more stories podcasts forget that
but that's corporate stuff and jay mohr
and dirty sock I jay mohr 37 oh is it
three years seven ng Morris squatted on
my name that'll happen so it's at gym or
37 which was the year we were both born
my father was born in nineteen thirty
yeah my brother uses a the number 0 12 I
think 44 things cuz for some reason it
was George Carlin's favorite number I
think it was the Judy that my father
came back into our lives and fixed his
life it's so beautiful that's so
beautiful mr. Carlin Tonya and you're a
comedian it's always obsessed with
twelves was he hmm my wife she's asian
numerologist uh no I just had weird
stuff you know that he dug like my
wife's a big eight first she likes eight
I like seven and it's because you mental
it's when I uh um it's when I first met
my my oldest nephew who he's ours like
he's my brother stepson and I love that
kid with the power of the Sun and I was
like sevens gonna be my favorite a good
number good good what's his name the
game's young Paul Boyer young Paul Boyer
and boys jay mohr telling you straighten
up fly right young man you got nothing
to worry about like that sounds like
that he's a he buys wine for some chain
of why seven year old nephew was one he
buys yeah it's nice I met him probably
30 years ago now he's probably maybe 25
he's probably 32 important piece of the
story you kind of reacted on meter yeah
yeah hey I like your app I have your
look yeah that's what I wanna you were
till night yeah I don't even have my a
dork forest app anybody in ICU yeah of
course let me take it off airplane mode
oh yeah um don't I have you and Greg
Proops and mine oh listen to make
scienter up some
so I only listen it's got the Ranger
image and then yeah really it's a good
app it's very easy you plug it in into
the car stereo and you just listen to
Jackie kid it's all good yeah that's
great oh wow and it goes back like
several like 30 episodes and i want to
tell you this nice thing that happened
about you was I was listening because I
have the proofs Greg Proops his app as
well i have an appt more stories app if
you guys wish um more stories with an h
that's right and Greg Proops was doing a
show at nerdmelt and he was going
through like you know he's got that
crazy like Secretary of State schedule
he always wants to like you know in the
12th I'll be in New Zealand on the 13th
I'll being one then I'll be in London
for 48 hours everyone in Japan that'll
be at nerd mouth gonna be at bar louie
and then i'm into the dark forest
podcast for Jackie Kashian and like huge
applause oh that's great yes I was like
oh I gotta get in there oh yeah you got
it yeah you gotta you gotta called you
that day that you did call me that day
so inspired you to to say hey let me get
back on the dork forest yeah I wanted to
go on anyone listening who's on a long
line that jay mohr just jumped squeaky
wheel you guys that's how you get on the
dork for that's a new jagah dates to
promote that's really how like when
podcasts episodes get shelved it's like
hey man they just had dates to promote
yeah I can't if I'm gonna be you know at
stand up live right you got in october
seven house of blues and thanks phoenix
for 22nd yeah phoenix october 22nd stand
up live so I know fans of both of those
places got a joke around there jump the
line and this uh yeah it's so how is
your app is weakly I'm sure the phone
bonus do you ever listen to the phone
bonus which is only available on the app
i don't know what i mean so apparently
no there's a bonus that libsyn cuz lips
and created the app and they they're
like you can put additional content and
it'll just play on the app it'll be
bonus content so it's one two three
minutes of me and anti-aircraft my fella
by the way cuz dude man that's nice you
walk in somebody's house at nine o'clock
in the morning and the husband Stan and
they're usually it's like uh hi very
warm easygoing I was nice he's a morning
person really it's nice you and I are
sitting here I got it with her
we're resting our chins on the mic yeah
hey you bastard oh my god or phone
content phone yeah it's got the phone
bonus and so why we get in touch with
Lisbon well let me let me see it again
it's I don't know why the more store by
AJ and by the way everybody they're
talking about we don't exactly like
we're not asking you get our apps
because like we get paid from it oh my
god not all there so no no money no but
we really want you to get the app
because it's super convenient for you
just to listen to us like on all your
devices and in your cars and on
airplanes people like it some people
really do like a device let me tell you
something when I discovered podcasts
myself yeah ah you don't care about
being in traffic at all like you talking
about Houston like you're on that
Beltway just sitting there you want
destiny what do you listen to you right
troops urine and I've Greg Proops in you
I'm right now dear ones you're listen to
alicia tyler yeah um everybody she pulls
like some guests out like she went the
high school with sam rockwell and I'm
like I want Sam Rockwell so bad I know
when there's podcast guest envy it gets
against any coup Mia I have his a
patterner who that is you wouldn't I
don't know anybody is you know that L or
you know Martin do you know Laurie
Kilmartin she relates a Paul no she was
one of your guests I just listened to us
awesome work Paul Gill Gilmore there you
go paul Blart Lori yes here's the
weirdest thing is the phone dullness
isn't here's the Paul Gilmartin episode
it's not showing up on the audio post so
maybe there's more to it who knows down
but we have apps people get our apps are
you on libsyn is that who uploads you is
this did they make your app or did you
haven't made separately I don't know
somebody said it would have been lips I
said we need to get a nap and then a
friend of mine said I'll take care of it
oh my gosh so don't put old ones up like
you know David Lee Roth has an old like
I got weird people on like you got some
awesome people on there but I can I put
like my pre stolen too yeah Monsignor
Jim la santé from Long Island I always
like to play devil's advocate like I
know what all the atheists are yelling
at the radio you know I am from a family
of devil's advocate why what draws you I
is it what makes you want to say you
know what
I want to be the devil in this
particular conversation I want to
represent the constituents today use the
devil's a bad guy right why would you
want to advocate for that guy who has me
put me personally why do I want to do it
to like a priest is it yeah I have a lot
of listeners at are atheists and I know
what's running through their minds and
you don't want to ask that question for
going down okay uh without without ever
shoving and pushing him oh no without
ever shoving Catholicism done anybody's
throat I know an atheist is going like
hot you can't you know whatever the
question would be but I do get really
good stuff out of I've had my father
Willie's been on twice and all my
priests are like young cool guys like
father Willie and I by my youth at the
same gym and he's from like Maine he was
like a state champion box and they all
had like lives before they had like
they're calling yeah and like father Tim
I surf with and home he was like a party
guy in like actin oh yeah we gotta
listen to the surfing episode I've of
the certain idea Murray uh valeriano and
at an Australian guy whose name is I did
listen to it yeah and you were getting
recessed with long word versus short
boards well I was getting obsessed with
the fact that you wait you carry your
board around with you did you have heavy
I mean I was all your questions where I
thought your questions were completely
salient points and you were acting as if
what you're asking them was like the
like I'm sorry to ask you another
ridiculous question I was like well know
if I'm Jackie Kashian I've never surfed
these are great question they're good
they're perfectly and Marie told me at
the end of it he said you know you
didn't ask me afterwards he said you
know you didn't ask like the main three
questions everybody asked surfers will
made it more interesting for us like I
guess the main three questions people
get asked her something about sharks and
something about I don't know no I I
asked those three sharks yeah more
sharper than some other sharks I'm known
for not asking the right questions I
interviewed Bill Willingham was a comic
book guy at the ed i got off stage and
andy's giant comic book guy goes you
know you didn't ask him anything about
comics and you didn't ask him anything
like what people usually ask him at
conventions and stuff because it was a
live episode at a con and I was like
well he was it he was in Vietnam II was
who he was a tank operator I wanted to
talk about
that I think are interesting that's
fascinating and everyone enjoyed that
episode so it all worked out what does
Andy know what does Andy don't he was
actually used he was applauding it he
said you're right everybody knows more
than they've ever they've heard him talk
about fables and his comic so you did
let's talk to come your dorkdom okay
yeah I'm a little I get obsessive about
some dorky stuff that people probably
wouldn't think a great because I school
wrestler right slow clap job anymore oh
yeah you grind up you joined me slow
clap yeah it is a cop no i didn't know i
was a jog would you cuz weird I played
baseball wait and wrestling I wrestled
and it was when Brian Posehn was on my
podcast he called me a jock and I'm like
I'm not a jock he's like all right look
at me right yeah look at you I go all
right but we're like we're comment like
once you're a comic is that you're
trying your yeah yeah he goes did you
get a varsity letter in a sport I said
yes he said how many and I said which
sport and he goes you're an [ __ ]
hahaha see here so but the thing is is
you you you email me your like this list
of dork tubes that we could talk about
the one that this is I have a bone to
pick with people who love the Real
Housewives and you know it's not to love
well not only do I love it I used to
blog on Bravo whatever their website is
yeah the real housewives of new jersey
my home state and I did it for free I
did it for the passion of Teresa and Joe
Giudice and the battle they had but the
Gorgas why it's a growing me oh and
Juliet it was crazy and I blogged for
free for an entire year and I was still
intermittently on my Twitter hey one of
your blog's coming back and I'm like I
can't keep doing that it takes hours
right cuz you gotta watch it and I do it
right yeah gotta make it funny and
entered am so let's start early on
because I've never I've not seen one of
them okay not even one so there's many
different franchises what was the first
one who were the orange county was the
first one and it sold it Bravo sold it
as gated communities it wasn't
housewives okay like the way it was
written it was like
people yeah you know and there was a
stat in the opening credits like you
know there's 300 million Americans 19
million live behind gated walls like it
was casa de Coteau this place in Orange
County but then the franchise as it
stands now is just the Real Housewives
yeah of all these different cities which
is fascinating because none of them are
housewives right like bethenny frankel
like Real Housewives of New York runs
like skinny girl she created that
conglomerate like she's as big as Pepsi
Cola Wow and she lived with lonely girl
skinny girl is like a cocktail mix like
skinny girl wine skinny girl mixers it
like a diet boo thing yeah that's what
is well I know what the world has always
wanted a diet booze thank you you all
like wind up doing cookbooks they all
know they all have was there housewives
but they're there quote housewives yes
and they're there it's amazing to me cuz
like as a comic you're always like
where's my ancillary income gonna come
from book might do a podcast like these
ladies will do like cookbooks are like
they're really songs what you're allowed
to record music a lady from Atlanta Kim
Zolciak tardy for the party don't be
tardy for the party be tardy for the
band like for like a summer they'll be
like hit like LuAnn de Lesseps the
countess Real Housewives of New York
elegance what money can't buy you class
elegans his learn my friend and then
yeah Melissa Gorga Real Housewives of
New Jersey had on display a song and
here's where I had to completely tap out
of the housewife stuff is when I got
into a Twitter battle with a housewife
Oh with an actual housewife yes if your
God well enough that they will talk to
you if you wrestle with pigs you get mud
on you and the pig enjoys it right
that's the only person having a good
time so I tapped out completely of the
Twitter waging the war that I was in
with this melissa gorga lady and where
it went out wearing what city is she
from New Jersey okay and so what I did
instead was when I went as a guest on
watch what happens live my friend Andy
Cohen's got this great show it's like
just nonsensical fun with hella like a
housewife and like it's panel yes sort
of it's a half the huge so it's a
best-case scenario it's him and in
there's two chairs there's a bar okay
and just super fast it'll be like a
housewife and Jackie Kashian or two
housewives or it'll be like I'm so Katie
Couric and like a husband of a housewife
okay gets huge guests all right but I
was the first like straight male that
was all in right right that you were
like I know everything you can you can
go toe-to-toe with these people and so I
was on it and what I did instead to get
out of the Melissa Gorga cuz my whole
thing was like her sings her song stinks
right I mean she's like on Twitter this
one back and forth it was ridiculous and
then people that enjoy Real Housewives
franchises right or so ah they're crazy
they're pretty passionate er that's one
that's a word yeah I'll say bat guano
check the floors and great check the
floors of the caves for bat [ __ ] cuz
they're hanging upside down crazy oh my
god so team will It's Always team this
team that team Melissa went crazy like
you doing in a stunt like this is a
great song she's talented so when I was
a guest on watch what happens live I my
wife who has all the great ideas in my
life hmm she said you have to you have
to do the song when you're there oh I
remember oh wait Joey you're on the show
yes I was a guest on watch what happens
live I brought out an acoustic guitarist
and I just banked out like a super quiet
like Chet Baker version of this girl
then plug bhp one day every day on
display and like just nailed it like it
won and it was great like game over like
this I can do no auto-tune there's some
ginger guitarist some red heavy guy just
walk it around guy you're like hey you
play what's yeah this it was fine that's
funny didya did he have to was it hard
for him to learn the song or is it one
of the simple tunes of the world
it was maybe maybe you didn't hear the
real housewives of new jersey as the
artist her right did she supposedly
right the tomb mmm that well the whole
season was her with the Gravediggaz
spell be like yeah naturally Oh coming
to her home and her husband Joe Gorga
building her like this fantastic
recording studio so the the other
premise there was something who was it
who had the idea I need a beer yeah yeah
what's up dorks you're a dreamer man
that's Jim Koch calls you did you see
that they're not I like to thank David
Lee Roth works in a coke factory little
dreamer they don't think they're not put
names on them anymore what's happening a
dream with your say-so box wherever no I
don't know what that it doesn't say
isn't weird that is super weird but okay
so there's like there's five of these
shows though right there's new york city
house was in new york city the first one
was orange county ok new york city
atlanta right uh Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills Oh Beverly Hills oh that's
a really good one that was a lot of
drama yeah because they're all so
[ __ ] rich right breathe lazy rich
right most of these they're all pretty
wealthy or do you think they're
subsidized by the reality TV industry
they become wealthy for like that okay
but you're only doing like 12 because
people that's it for the civilians
listening you go like hey I made a ten
thousand dollars a week doing I guessed
a you know TV show and everybody's like
why you're a millionaire you go no it's
13 weeks and then I have nothing right
right on it what the government takes
fifty percent because they think you're
making that all 52 weeks right all right
so I think those housewives you know
they make like but they keep that was in
dollars 0 for the season / episode Oh
perhaps it's gotten nuts like it's the
episodes per season 12 13 14 15 personal
appearance you drop it right hit record
in the Hamptons right who doesn't love
books I don't watch Atlanta so much
because there's just too many wigs I'm
it's a it's like more of a black real
hair yeah it's more like black women
there's one white lady Kim Zolciak who
hasn't um tardy for the party and it's
been up they get spin-off shows okay um
Real Housewives of New Jersey we
mentioned what what's one of the spin
actual New Jersey uh Caroline Manzo
who's actually a friend of mine through
just being the blogs and stuff and being
a voice of sanity on this complete crazy
Guido show uh her and I like text back
and forth she's been on the podcast and
stuff like that and she's got nice kids
like her son's would come to my stand-up
shows when i was on the east coast she
is a show growing up manzo'd because her
she's becoming an empty-nester an alert
okay no uh but like her husband owns
this enormous restaurant in New Jersey
called the brownstone it's like where
you have like weddings and stuff okay
and it's weird because like that's where
I grew up and I used to work at this
place to friar tuck n which looks the
same so like whenever they visit him at
work I'm like flashback to yeah this is
like right like I get exactly do at that
job I was a waiter I became an alcoholic
too cuz when you're 16 and somebody goes
you want to help me bartend you go sure
and wow these Budweiser bottles come in
six ounces I can put this down pretty
quick ya know it will notice I was great
it was a good time to be a drunk well so
okay so you have watched you really I
love your passion by the way ok hearing
about what the hell yeah like the surfer
guys I feel like I'm well here's the
thing with reality TV to the fascinates
me that I dorks me out is that they they
think they're like on TV TV cuz like
when they walk down the street people go
Vicky and like they scream right they
think that they're Cary Grant and
Katharine Hepburn yeah and it's like no
you're on reality TV and reality TV I've
been offered it yeah me and my wife and
it's like up because we were in the mix
with Bravo with the blogs and it's like
oh no no no no because once you let them
in you can never say that's enough like
you know I with my kid at the third
street promenade
could you guys screw off you know yeah
uh no you know and you see it like every
at the end of the paint when Jenner ah
that's I mean that's turned into such a
horrible like I don't know when Bruce
Jenner wanted to get out of that
situation of the Kardashians Jewish
there was no way to get out of it I'll
not do anything I don't lay on the like
the day players like Scott Disick okay
like he makes seventy-five thousand
dollars in episode and he's like just
married to the little one he's married
to one of the Kardashian kids girls
women Khloe he's married to Kourtney's
Khloe's the big one with Lamar Odom
right I don't know you miss Cal I know
is that at least once a week I get a
hilarious tweet telling telling me that
the Kardashians are one syllable away
from keishon and you're like yes yes i
get what youre i I don't know what
you're saying but it doesn't seem
flattered everybody tweet me that
instead of don't go don't tweet at
Jackie Kashian tweet at Jane were 37 and
spare her that way to send it my way oh
and by the way i do want to know Rangers
that you listen so I would actually in
all earnestness and honesty would love
it if you hit me up I don't care if you
follow me do whatever you want to do it
your life you didn't you get my echo see
him over at Houston on october 17th or
in Phoenix and I'm for 20 seconds you
don't have to but you could go to jail
bore calm and a lot of content a lot of
content ID myself on that site lot of
content on that side well here's that
thing it's a rabbit hole it is a rabbit
hole I'm not joking yeah you can be on
my site for an hour there's enough weird
videos and dress it's chase but the
thing with the podcast do is hit
subscribe to more stories you didn't
have to listen to it it costs you
nothing hit subscribe button get the app
me and Jackie get credit for it you
didn't walk away from the it's a
dumpster fire to you for all I know just
but I need to know that you peek inside
and bounce out that right right and just
saw so what it was like what do you want
to know about these ladies how do I got
you oh by the way yeah I am the only
person ever you should be a guest host
on watch what happens live on Bravo okay
no one has ever first of all how Andy
what happens live just sort of a panel
show
about live about reality television
about the Real Housewives and blow debt
all yes all the Bravo throb only Robin
yeah and Andy Cohen yeah oh he'll do
tell that if it's what I don't know if
that's what ever it is on Bravo's and
yes okay and there's two guests and
they'll be like a star like bartender
okay all right no I look who came over
row thought that guy exact the exact
second he does good point so you were
you were a guest host I was in New York
doing stand-up Andy Cohen was on you
have to keep doing the Real Housewives
of Orange County reunion in Orange
County and he couldn't get back in time
and they said would you be able to guest
host and I was like oh yeah yes this is
and it's live which as you know is the
greatest most fun it's high wire much
more fun shoe cards and teleprompters
everywhere right like anything that's
not on camera there are words written
down for you you should be saying these
things you wear an IFB in your ear which
for the listener is about the size of a
peanut flesh-colored you never see it
and that means they go and 92 commercial
so like a three-second you go we'll be
right back with more right after the
agency while you're talking sometimes I
couldn't do that I mean maybe I would
learn me it's me it might just be like a
battle helmet that miles workers can
have some that one book I read anyway uh
tell me about that that you lost me I
want I don't like to be lost well you
don't like to be it's a science fiction
he was I'm gonna talk to this guy you
know we all motor oil we're don't post
more how I'm the drowsy chaperone I'm
rodeo fall musical theater what a guy
that wrestled in college can knows you
know about what I can't like Sweeney
Todd Rodolfo was drowsy chaperone never
mind forget it so what in Sweeney Todd
no no i said i just mentioned yeah I'm
big sean time guy Jim Jefferies and I
had a very odd episode of more stories
where we talked about musical theater I
looked at my watch it been an hour in 10
minutes anyway here's one for the books
here's one yeah like two guys you would
Jim Jefferies like two guys you would
never
think i went to hedwig last winter hey
chula with Neil Patrick Harris no it was
with the guy the original guy whose name
is no names the guy wrote it he was in
the movie I think I want to know Billy
the guy from Chicago Richard Gere played
he's got two songs I don't know so what
do songs he owe this all he has ok Billy
forget his name that's in Chicago
Richard Gere did it in the movie ok any
uh like if I did Broadway I'm like I
don't know how good I can sing or how
terrified I will be on Broadway but I
know if I do Chicago it's just those two
songs right yeah no II that take some
beta blockers like a bit i'll take it
like a xanax bar or something a bar and
just sing right super fun yeah okay i'm
back to the real hole oh yeah so I guess
toasters how many members are in each a
455 usually around they try to do five
yeah like what happens is you'll get
your core and then two will go away and
you replace them sometimes in a workout
well they'll just be like I'm done I'm
storming out about twelve dollars
sometimes like Real Housewives of New
York City my own car was a lady Jill
Zarin ok was a complete Yenta like that
thought thought that the like never
stopped like chatty Magoo oh and
everybody's business and it was great TV
yeah yeah but she became a bit of uh do
you know who i am and then she went to
Bravo and demanded a whole bunch of
stuff and they're like how about this
here's the option B go [ __ ] yourself and
she left and we were watching The Real
Housewives of New York reunion my wife
and I and I said to my wife do you think
Jill zarin's just watching this right
now weeping cuz now they're all getting
like I said like fifty thousand dollars
a week it's crazy right right and deals
and whatever else they want orange
county the first two seasons there was a
lady waiter start like 2006 I feel like
it's been around Easter doesn't late two
thousand late trying to be cool what is
right when your nephew
right when you found your nephew oh
really that would have a 97 you go so
right there it says that one it all came
together I don't know when you're 2,000
when at least 10 years he's think things
have been around i feel like i don't
know i'm gonna guess I'll take the
underboss a 9 i'm not sure but you're
right you're right in the wheelhouse ok
so like Orange County housewives there
was a lady I forget her name but she
married a guy and her leading up to it
like they were dating she had a horrible
like marriage previously she had really
cool kids and then she just met this
like guy who was an actual billionaire
mm-hmm they got married and they didn't
get married like on the show like it
wasn't one anybody had not mastered no
he actually was okay with it oh but they
had not mastered the monetizing of every
like everything you don't I mean right
so she got married to like this
billionaire and she just kind of tapped
out everyone smile she'll come back but
like she left for that reason right um
how old are they would like is anyone
who did started doing it five or seven
years ago still doing Vicki Gundel gun
falls at Gunvalson in Orange County
still she's an OG okay or original and
new york is uh let's see LuAnn de
Lesseps she she's the countess she
married a guy who was account a genuine
count so she was the countess and that
was like that's the thing my wife and I
split on she really likes LuAnn I like
LuAnn too but the countess stuff I'm
like you know what when you marry into
it yeah easy when you're telling
Bethenny's listen when you introduce me
to the driver it's mrs. de Lesseps don't
call me LuAnn okay and my wife goes well
that's probably her husband gave around
here and you're beating because of it
and I go yeah but it's Bethenny's driver
right you know what I mean yeah it's my
friend LuAnn lesson listen you need to
still a sense and I'm mrs. jim dilla sep
and she did like a hinge for Heloise
like a countess like how to behave book
oh and then that guy cheated on her and
they got a divorce all public all on the
show right so now she's single gift of a
half of his income er I would hope so
okay ass way it goes isn't it the way it
goes of ug I've been there oh I've not
cheated but okay
we're giving somebody everything I
bought everything and then you're like
oh I didn't need that anyway what's you
know what's great about that though it
was great about it all the money that I
left on the table because of either my
behavior or terrible decision making
would have went to someone else anyway
so I have no regrets oh there you go
like I can't believe I turned down those
1-800 call ATT come on ap the
commercials like not doesn't matter you
wouldn't have it yeah you woulda lost
that no that would have been don't work
anyway oh geez yes from the start Vicky
gun fillol Gunvalson Vicky on an orange
county man Vicky Bethenny was in the
first season of New York City left
because she became a billionaire right
then had a talk show that didn't work
right then she came back and it was this
year how do you do they have the
personality to sustain something like a
talk show I mean they must be smart but
many did yes some of them really are
interesting mm-hmm some of them are dumb
as bags of hair like just right just
human walking around yeah piece of sand
so and they're all what are they like 35
are they younger 25 well their faces are
about two or three oh so they're older
yeah they're in their 40s or 50s or what
yeah 40 50 60 I don't know there's one
lady on Orange County that's nice she
had to be a reason to watch it if you're
sitting in the middle of Indiana you're
like oh look there's a woman my age and
I can watch your old face with a
two-year-old face and for some reason an
eleven-year-old and and but but at least
they're not 12 you know a lot of the
other older gals like yeah there's a lot
of facelifts and a lot of Botox and a
lot of IVF what's IVF in vitro
fertilization oh we're all right okay
tool to make a kiss baby yeah yeah yeah
fair enough ah has to be done so are
they are doing a personality to carry
something on their own Bethany is
mercurial to say the least Bethany
frightened so they gave her talk show
and I don't think it worked obviously
cuz she's back uh-uh no no
not not yet not so as a group 1 through
you know 30 no well there's a couple
outliers where you're like oh except
read any like genuine breakout stars
NeNe Leakes Nene lishi was on like parks
and rec oh she's the black lady that was
like blonde wigs on Atlanta ok she got a
crick any Andy NeNe Leakes okay like she
got crazy famous okay uh so she actually
started an acting career from this org
or yeah and it went where it went away
it didn't stick um not to my knowledge
but I get I don't get lucky and fun yes
and I don't watch the Atlanta one
because you know it's not for you it's
also too it's black housewives and then
just being completely honest and when
people get uncomfortable like when you
talk about race I like talking about it
because it's I like talking about in
elevators I like to just bring it up
like I work at a car bucks asians right
before you go um but I don't I can like
New Jersey we talked about I worked at a
type of Porter's throw jersey verona 0 7
0 for 4 in the shadows of giant stadium
in the Meadowlands okay so like Atlanta
yeah these black women in their lives I
can't really relate to what's going on
because I don't sucked in I just don't
know I can't relate you're not yeah it's
not I don't know how you can relate to
the new jersey old ladies how hours I'm
from New Jersey and like these are the
ladies that grew up with all the way
he's on my street okay how you doing on
are you i right uh JJ how are ya and
then he wants a veal parmesan I just
made it did you like the sopranos love
the Safari we can't boys oh yeah it was
a little tense I said Dean Del Rey on my
podcast and we're talking about
overrated we I wanted a complete
underrated list across the board and
then I got obsessed I dorked out on
since the Rangers are listening yep i'll
use the denominator yeah yeah i worked
out on things that are a plus great but
yet still underrated Paul McCartney okay
completely underrated as a base weird
because he's not living check to check
that guy we're not working out but
that's you know i'm joining in the
shadow of john lennon i guess and so he
get along good side of that meat
nah music wise music fans know that Paul
wrote eighty percent of everything and
they came up with the concept albums of
like magical mystery tour and so you
feel but you still feel he's underrated
or he isn't valued as greatly as he
ought to be I think people know he's
Paul McCartney's a beetle but I don't
think people realize I mean he wrote
helter skelter for crying out loud he's
a bassist he plays left I have I had
that one for conversation and wings is
great well it work it's a two disc thing
one is the hits and one is the the other
like they're like something like 30
number one hits right from wings and
then the other is like the Bell is like
b-sides or something right and but what
I what I listening to that in my car I
am struck by and I don't know I know
very little about a lot of music but
what I am struck by the songs of wings
or the songs in this compilation is that
they seem to be two or three songs in
one song like it'll be very Paul like
you never give me your money off of that
be road okay the bass lines and stuff
like talking about Paul McCartney's a
bassist completely underrated like he
never comes up okay every always goes
John Paul Jones from like Led Zeppelin
or Bill Wyman or you know the guy from
the WHO and whistle or whatever but like
yeah Paul uh was just a phenomenal basis
but Goodfellas Dean Del Rey goes I'm not
a Goodfellas guy we didn't like the
movie Goodfellas I was like what cuz you
said about the sopranos right not your
cup of tea but like sopran uh Goodfellas
I don't even though we think it's a plus
yeah it's underrated because every time
you watch it you're like [ __ ] I didn't
realize that I write it was that guy
Anthony or it's better than you remote
its just oh I think I Anthony has four
lines but he's never on camera like
that's really weird yeah there's not a
bad scene in Goodfellas oh there is a
guy that none of his lines are on camera
oh yeah I want you to look out for okay
Anthony his name they shoot spider in
the foot well first of all when uh
you're funny how what's so funny about
me yeah maybe maybe I'm [ __ ] up maybe
it too much to drink I don't know he hey
Joey you got it all wrong he's a big boy
Anthony let him speak for himself right
that's off camera in the restaurant yep
then when he shoots Christopher
from the sopranos right I thought you
said on my right spider uh he goes you
shot him in the [ __ ] fun and then you
here off camera how could you miss from
this distance right and then Pesci looks
at the guy off camera and he goes the
problem what I did Anthony and he goes
no he's never on camera I the think what
i like about Goodfellas is that it is a
depiction of the mob that feels so
incredibly real that I've never been
I've watched that movie probably three
times in 25 years because it's too real
i watch it's three times in 25 minutes
oh I believe that i just snorted snorted
adderall it's you know that i tried to
watch all the hot top 100 a fi movies on
fast-forward I was like people want me
to watch all this [ __ ] fine here we
go some of them are terrible some of
them are fun some of that no no some of
them about it some of the martyr someone
there are [ __ ] garbage movies some of
these like all-time classics right
[ __ ] that you did that and it's a
waste of your time and same with books
like people go you know the classics
like Moby Dick Moby Dick I will wipe my
ass with it's a pile of [ __ ] I remember
how you try to I I tried to tried as an
adult een I didn't in high school I
couldn't get through it grind sorry i
did i did cliff notes in high school and
uh gotta thoughts are better yeah well
here's the thing i just started
rereading it um and you Cara Lee you
care at all about it not yet why are you
on I'm 32 you should care by now and I
should character I have a 50-page thing
in my head by 50 pages if i don't care i
just put it away well here here's what i
will say about Moby Dick is that truly
I'm plagued yeah absolutely no when I
was a kid I had a hard time reading it
cuz I tried to care about wailing like
they would talk about scrim shying and
and all of this different wailing terms
and I was like who cares uh now I don't
have to care I can skim over those words
Melville got paid by the word but nobody
knows uh that's why right no he did okay
that's why it makes me so incensed when
I read it as an adult and I like to
think I'm of above-average intelligence
and I really
of literature I'll sit down from anne
sexton poetry too but i got you that's
their favorite book Moby Dick yeah
they're dollard's don't be friends with
me look I got the page 180 they're not
in [ __ ] water okay it's Moby the
whale right so like what are we doing in
this in this little [ __ ] village
can't see already well the first 30
pages it seems sorry political
indictment I guess whatever i got it i
don't want i just read into yes crow
shoot I don't what is great into great
darkness something like it was about a
whaling expedition from Nantucket they
get sperm whales but they go there's no
competitor well it's all whales they're
in the water right away right away with
the walls fascinating am a huge they
don't have a panama canal then okay
1800s right so these old ass wooden
boats go all the way down the eastern
seaboard around the Cape of whatever it
is yep up chilly and then like that's
where they get their whales and throw
away for two and a half years right
right and they come back and they make
their money and they're like oh wow okay
oh yeah I have three kids yeah look at
this fascinating but Moby Dick yeah I'd
like no it's terribly fahrenheit 451
fantastic if you think it's about
whaling you were it's doomed you are
doomed don't ever eat I just don't read
Moby Dick yeah just get our ABS will
tell you what you're missing I'm sitting
here with J bar is taking a stand
against moby dick you got horrible you
think it's not horrible I don't think
it's horrible i think that it's actually
pretty funny I'd like I'm 30 pages and
I'm like this is actually quite clever
and kind of funny it's dry I'm not gonna
I mean I haven't finished it no one ever
i I just has ever referred to Moby Dick
is funny but and you're not that ironic
no I'm not I am a simple woman of the
people jay mohr yeah I mean I that's why
I'm like surprised yeah I know you're
like me you have no irony in your body
I'm wearing a Hello Kitty know if I have
a Hello Kitty t-shirt on it's cuz i
[ __ ] love Hello Kitty right I don't
wear anything ironically or you don't go
see Neil Diamond for a hoot like and now
I'm going to see [ __ ] Neil Diamond
I'm rockin out might like to see Neil
Diamond actually that would be fun whoa
whoa
oh and you stand up and scream I so I'm
at Staples Center we scream so loud whoa
whoa whoa hoping he would just stop and
point as the greatest goddamn ooo's I've
ever heard you know that I slightly
ironically but because it was so
horrible here's what i ended up one day
watch this Tom Jones sloop John B music
video from British television from like
1969 Tom Jones is standing in a white
speedo with a captain's hat there's
nothing ironic yeah no he is not ironic
you said you wash it ironically to some
extent I watched it because it was like
I amazingly horrible yeah like I had to
go youtube this on my phone when I'm oh
my truck at a red light right now like
I'm not but yes I'm down he is it is the
most viscerally sexual thing he's
standing on this boat he is clearly at
any point about to just get just mobbed
by these women who all just want to suck
on some part of his body just his feet
doesn't matter it doesn't matter so it
is clearly killing what I say I like
that he was but he's wearing a white
sweet oh and I egg captain's hat yeah
and you're like what is happening here
and then but this not what's happening
it's what's being set up to happen well
and then later somebody had somebody
posted Prince um doing a guitar solo in
some Beatles song and I in a George
Harrison retrospective and it was
genuinely some of the finest music
Prince is underrated well it would seem
to creep at Coachella nope been
Radiohead no I don't changes it too i
wish one princess i wish i were special
yeah cuz im so [ __ ] spike cuz
Radiohead is I wish I was special oh
yeah and print-only friends yeah wish
you were special cuz i'm so [ __ ]
special yeah he's pretty Gemma green
yeah um I have a comedy album happy and
a lot on iTunes that my wife and a lot
my wife wrote the entire hour it was a
showtime special oh she wrote the
standard written by nikki cox okay
warmed by jay mohr entry was I doing a
Mamet play it was the most nerve-racking
cuz you had to get the words right yes
stand up and she
is like a solo show more than stand up
she's a genius she's right she's an
insomniac so I'll wake up and she'll
hand me a notebook and I'll breed like I
was just an Irvine and I just went up
there with like three pages in my pocket
yeah and like none of it has to be
worked out workshop like it is like what
this text that's written that's how it
goes yeah like midgets in front of us is
average like [ __ ] you I'm not ever like
this whole long bit like that was this
weekend okay oh I start my album itunes
happy period and a lot period well if
you're a gal and uh one to fifty percent
of us are respect a gal who gets no
credit ever and that's my wife but she
doesn't want to perform she just wants
to write for you well she's a great
actress I mean she bought a house at 16
for crying she was been aunty she was in
Paula Abdul videos at a chance for
Michael Jackson a date did she grow up
here yeah Santa Monica that'll do it uh
now she's like a mom and she only wants
to do words she's proud of he just wants
to write no she wants to act again but
she wants it to be words cuz she look it
was like he doesn't have we ever after
oh no no right oh yes right son happily
ever after was like a sitcom with a
puppet ok a bit like a rabbit puppet
okay he's a guy that did um Jerry Cohen
and um Ron Levitt who did uh Meredith
children okay was the other one mm-hmm
and it was like Kevin Connolly Bobcat
Goldthwait was the voice of the rabbit
right um Jeff Pearson who went on to
play the president 19 different times uh
then after that it was like she went
like from that then she did her own show
called Nikki on the WB I the same time
nick von s mark played her husband it
was like a dear friend you played a pro
wrestler and she was a showgirl and
every show open with like these
elaborate dance numbers and then at the
same time she went across the lot and
she was a guest star a norm for two
seasons okay uh one of the most
underrated shows ever is the norm show
and then not like Donald yes of course
and then Las Vegas for six years so like
right and in between all that she's in
like mr. shell movie and like doing
so so so she works it's fine but it is
always either sitcom Murray yep where
Las Vegas she refers to as The Love Boat
okay Donny Osmond's here this week
literally no literally tanya is here
this week right and I have to show him
how to get to the Peach Pit watch watch
ciarra sing right so she wants act again
but when its words that she's proud of
right she doesn't want to just act like
just she wants to do something shame for
the money fair enough so she wrote the
entire hour and and so it's available on
CD is it and you know on itunes download
on itunes but uh happy in a lot is it a
hard copy at all can people get it's a
DVD video not yet cuz showtime owns it
okay i only made sure i push the itunes
release because i want to get nominated
for a grammy so yeah that's better okay
i was talking to Lisa Lampanelli
universe man yes he Lampanelli got
nominated for a grammy right for comedy
album was when she was on my more
stories okay and I was like oh like as
she's talking with him three years ago
and as she's talking to me I just
completely fade out it's like a scene
from like all that jazz right there like
just her mouth and I'm like I can't
known him for a [ __ ] Grammy mm-hmm
like that's too bizarre and then she
said she was up against Harry Shearer
George Lopez steven wright like these
are people like where if you don't win
you're fine but what are you gonna do
it's Harry Shearer Stephen rights George
Lopez yeah [ __ ] flight of the
conchords wins yeah like if you talk to
her about it she'll start yelling like
those Kiwi mother yeah out of all the
people right all right but just what the
flight of the conchords are amazing
there no Harry Shearer Stephen right at
George look I'm right look I am a hack
from way back look stimulus response how
many laughs are there I know there's art
to it yeah I enjoy the pauses as much
more than they shall they celebrate the
silence in a way that is very uh that is
very new zealand ii by they ain't harry
shearer steven wright george lopez they
know it's so dry it crackles uh they are
not and in a good way though
it's there i mean the thing is maybe
thing i would rate a sample i would have
been mad if i losted that you're gonna
be bad if you don't win no that's not
true I've lost before if harry shearer
would have beat me yes the steven wright
mabie george lopez Lisa Lampanelli [ __ ]
them yeah [ __ ] I don't I don't talk him
right in here well no it's a bet I'm I'm
as good as either of them quite honestly
and I know you actually George Lopez is
amazing George Lopez is amazing at what
he does Lisa Lisa Lampanelli is actually
amazing at what she does but it is not
necessarily for me but what you're doing
but I love what Steven Wright does and I
love what Harry Shearer does you know
what's amazing was stupid right this
leavin rights the only comedian in the
history of comedy mm-hmm that started at
two thousand see theaters mm-hmm and 30
years later the trajectory is exactly
the same there's been no Seng there's
been no sitcom there's been no like we
didn't see him mad about you for a
little bit sort of but like there's
never been like I gotta go do you know
bananas in Fort Lee New Jersey there's
no like arena knows no movie there's no
Sitka just to when he came out and we
knew he was 2000 see three doors and
just a straight like I have to tell you
my favorite Steven Wright story is that
he did a guest set uh at my home club
minneapolis acme comedy company which we
did your album that's good album and but
the not grammy-nominated turns out and
but the leader of mine right but the the
crazy thing is is so he just runs he's
running a five minute set for Letterman
was probably ten years ago and
afterwards people are going up and
introducing themselves uh my father
sadly I think said weren't you on
friends to him and he was very polite to
my dad anyway so it wasn't unfriends but
I wasn't a show called an amis once it
was a real and he showed me shout in my
garage was amazing I gave it a shot yeah
yeah that's not but it don't well my
favorite joke at that point was he had
this and you could do this in him voice
I can't do voices but it was I'm getting
an MRI tomorrow to find out if I have
claustrophobia that is the joke didn't
show the greatest jokes in the world of
two sentence jokes but some guy I'm Stan
Lee I understand the extra because I
think I was hosting at the time I
remember that shows is fantastic so I'm
standing next to him and the sky comes
up he's like huge fan getting an MRI
tomorrow to see if I have claustrophobia
yeah more pause in between em get
pressed on time so fly through it Oh
time so some guy goes up to the yemen's
his wife and so he's talking to him and
you know Steve Steven Wright perfectly
polite and he's like thanks I'm glad
your huge train it goes what happened
man and he literally is looking him in
the eye and it goes you were so big at
one point what to and he's like no I'm
working the walk i'm working the theater
and this weekend I'm it's gonna be and
you know you didn't say I make it 17
grand this weekend is that a is there
something wrong with that all right and
the guy is just like wooden and finally
Eddie would shut up he's like 35 a
minute half of this and finally Seaver
echoes hey you like baseball and the guy
goes yeah I said change the subject and
he just said it and it just it was the
greatest was perfect he just nailed the
guy I don't know I'm just even right may
not even remember that but I've I love
Steven right he's just incredibly smart
ease it just it's a bittersweet to watch
the gap why so one time he did it was on
his last special and I saw him doing it
on Letterman leading up to it but he did
a bit that was so unstable right because
the setup was so long oh wow it was like
when I was a kid I used to work in a
planetarium and Tyrone like first of all
know you're from all stunna like it see
it starts like wait why I don't ya like
workin it workin at a planetarium he
goes and we had a softball team and we
play other planetariums in the
neighborhood around surrounding cities
and we practice every night and of
course it's five times longer but then
every he goes he's ever written the
right now I'm doing it 20 times faster
than the actual joke uh it went on
forever like when we would rehearse the
1st baseman would stand him
second baseman would stand under Venus
shortstop stand on earth third bit and
he goes through all the planets all nine
positions well and that well Pluto's my
plan anymore i got the motive but
everybody fell but we know because uh
you know right fielder standing on the
Jupiter and just goes on yes then we had
our first game we had the fourth and
because we're all standing way too far
apart it was like wow you brought me on
a journey and close the gate behind me
before I knew it so okay Steven Wright
calm you guys go by that [ __ ] album
do ya know kid y minus Miller's got a
great you said cat scan Dennis Miller on
the off-white best album name ever the
off white album well that's funny uh I
just got back from LA los angeles the
only city where people list cat-scans as
film credits on their resume I was love
oh my god I saw him uh like four months
ago in Santa Barbara he was hanging out
with who was in 10 bo Derek and he lives
up there with John Corbett and John
quarter cup oh yeah right so corporates
a good dude right so John Corbett bo
Derek and uh Dennis Miller walk into a
bar no they all walk into the back good
looking through it there's a good look
at trio what I thought was a bo Derek
the nicest of the three quite honestly
like the only one who entered I was just
I was a minion so she introduced herself
to me and was very nice and I was like
she look all right Derek yeah i saw i
know Oprah is like super soul sunday or
something yeah I was like she looks
amazing she looks amazing and I don't
know if I I don't know if people have
had work cares i'm gonna get everything
done are you gonna get everything done
balding I need new veneers I got
medication to get my sperm count up and
makes my nipples which I'm like a 12
year old girl anyway i have to i [ __ ]
titties right now right now yes uh what
are scratch away what are so what's with
I want to get back oh sorry
I think is amazing it's uh though you
were to you were talking celebrities and
one of your other dark tones with
celebrity pets do you guys have a pet
I'm sorry Donald giant like cash flow
with their cat with their and yes
they're poking them yeah there's a dog
boo hoop your listeners might know the
Rangers you sex in the city Carrie Brett
s and I know every episode of Sex in the
City oh did you see the second movie I
didn't I actually thought it was fine I
was the worst you know how did you know
it was which it was what it was what it
was that's all I really did like the
first two seasons of Sex in the City
it's a perfect television show that's
what people don't understand no every
season is it 30 minutes of perfect
television you know how you know that
how do you know that because if you give
Miranda in rehearsal mm-hmm one of
Carey's lines of dialogue right the
entire set would go wait hold on a
second ok so the characters are so
they're set in stone right like Seinfeld
if Jason Alexander walked in and said
I'm taking my my rooster down to [ __ ]
fight you go wait no wait what no but if
thats Cranley yeah right so the
characterizations are very distinct
which which of the four would you be
which of which I'd be Carrie all day
yeah oh ok cuz I want to sleep with
Kristen off uh what I would be is I I
would be in the second movie I would be
the arab guy that gets to be Mario
Cantone I would be that I'd be the one
that gets them all arrested for being
ass hats uh cuz was it Miranda not
Miranda who's the one who is the
Samantha so there's whose is she the
Asian player no no the planner the the
party planner who gets them into
everything I don't know it's a she's
always sleeping with super young guys
and samantha is it Samantha the older
woman that's always tough that yeah they
slowly like him yeah and yeah so I I
would Kim control Kim Cattrall yeah I
would be the arab guy who got Kim
Cattrall arrested on family guy that uh
Kim Cattrall seen ya do the porch now
Rodolfo yeah that's great Kim Cattrall
is about to have sex on the family guy
and the guy jumped on top of her and she
smashed into dust
Wow but you were asked Oh sex in the
city yeah how do we get there oh we got
there I watch every episode some good
huh Oh so one day Carrie Bradshaw has
her book release okay and the lines
around the block and uh nobody comes up
two words they're all in line for boo
the dog really beautiful world's most
beautiful dog boo it's a little
Pomeranian okay so that got on my radar
it was hilarious okay then there's a dog
you can go on the website of the world's
most beautiful dog and the web page says
like is he a savant is he an alien is he
the Buddha and let you click here for
bookings and my friend told me about cat
con yeah and there's a cat little lil
bub little boys my phone guys it's great
what do you call that phone holder right
he's on his own case and a cat con like
comic-con you go and you walk around but
if you wanted a Polaroid with that
[ __ ] cat it's $175 and lil bub is
this not a kitten this is some sort of
you can just a beautiful can just been a
little white mint huh is it little
allowed kitten I mean smallish he's on
the small side okay but like just the
fact that you can get your cat $175 a
thousand people that's nuts right yeah
that is so I have three dogs they're on
my Instagram gym or sports okay and I
got a Yorkie named Mabel mm-hmm
beautiful I have a Maltese named dolores
de lago the toast of chicago uh not
beautiful kind of weird-looking right
her mustache gets yellow too quickly
what are you love her I gotta put on
marine Ian name security yep she's 3 /
out there all three pounds okay this
Pomeranian I'm going after Bo okay
you're gonna head to head this dogs way
more beautiful than boom Mabel if I got
on Mabel when she was like a year year
and a half years old two years old is it
cuz they're trained to do [ __ ] too can
they know they're just aesthetically so
pleasing to look at
they're models okay they can't talk just
like this year just like human being
models you can't have a conversation
with my pomeranian right and they'll
make you feel a little weird when you
walk away but I want to make a run at
these these [ __ ] to think like we
know you know the most beautiful animal
and I think like having some celebrity I
could actually if I really wanted to
write I gotta work an angle i think i
could that like actually bump boo or lil
bub or grumpy cat you've seen looks at
wilford brimley yep like I'm bumping
these [ __ ] out you like I can go to
like dog con right makes seven you know
100 and a hundred thousand dollars with
Polaroids yeah have you been a family
pet ancestry com all right uh I bought
it it's mine you mentioned it on your
podcast right because it's I don't know
you really did no I bought it cuz it's
funny cuz don't you want to know if your
cat came over on the Mayflower anyway
but it's easy after I did that joke on
Conan a guy actually emailed me and I
don't know if it's true I half of me
wants it to be true and half thinks that
he's a hilarious guy but he emails me is
like you know my cats actually direct
descendant of harry truman's cat and I
was like well that can't be true but
maybe it's true and it made me laugh so
oh my god hey jay mohr it's been an hour
by the way how did Harry truly have cats
well why would an airy German have cats
he's an American people's from Missouri
he's it from Independence Missouri you
think dogs yeah nice and nice sound
right he bombed Nagasaki for no reason
this is very simple and easy which
speaks volumes to how effortlessly you
are a guiding a conversation there we go
and an hour has passed and people go CJ
more he's gonna be october 17th in
houston house of blues in houston that's
it an october 27 at 20 seconds in
phoenix that whole weekend stand up live
22 23 24 with the el rey that'll be
great I want to see some Rangers bring
your dork forest of t-shirts to my shows
right and I can just say well I don't
pick on anybody ever in the audience you
never have to worry oh my self
absorption is complete I don't pick on
anybody you guys
too hard for 11 man yes it's what a you
go to j more calm you go at jay mohr 37
and jay mohr sports on Instagram yes
okay so get my app from my podcast get
your our stories he dot and a lot that
for my tunes and and go out there watch
little Real Housewives uh I really think
you're cool Jackie and also with you Jay
more I'd only you know you know we can
do any vodcast but I was like know how I
got you Jackie that's awesome man thanks
thanks love take care out there like I
had my hat my hat there dancing around
my hat hat my hat my hat but what do you
think of that if it looks like a Mexican
Hat dance and it sounds like a Mexican
Hat dance it's most likely a Mexican
jacket so take off your head and let
stand yay oh my god we why don't we just
call that as the end of the show